they're all those quantum guys okay so
let me get started Hey yes they're in oh
there's water there they are so I
covered a lot of measured theory
yesterday and then Mike miss love
covered even more domain theory today so
I thought today yesterday so I thought
today I should be a little bit light
there's going to be a lot of category
theory and I am on a unembarrassed about
it to get myself psyched for the
occasion Samson took me to a concert
where a singer called cat power so now I
feel empowered to do category theory so
as i said i would keep it at a very
elementary level and feel free to stop
me and ask me for example zort a boring
example show me another one was anything
like that so the domain team today is
what's the probabilistic analog of the
simple notion of binary relation so if
you look at things like label transition
systems what you have you have a set of
states you have some actions and
associated with every action you have a
transition relation so if you have
probabilistic transition relations a
probabilistic transition systems clearly
you ought to replace those ordinary
binary relations with probabilistic ones
so that seems like a nice prescription
if we only knew what these things were
so the point of today's lecture is to
try and explain that again by analogy
with ordinary relations so I will
actually discuss ordinary binary
relations you know the thing you learned
in kindergarten but I will try and then
lead you into monads and algebras to try
and show you how ordinary relations
emerge from a certain monad and then we
will look at the probabilistic analog of
this so first we have to look at the
category of measurable spaces because
the Monad that defines ordinary
relations comes on set monad that
defines probabilistic relations we live
on the category of
a sharable spaces and finally I will
show you the Monad the low veerji Ramona
and I'm afraid that I've got the accent
on Giri the wrong way but doesn't matter
so so the lower Jerry monad which is the
thing that generates probabilistic
relations and finally I will apply it to
give you formal semantics for Cozens
language with while loops which I talked
about on the first day okay so ordinary
binary relations you have sets and
relations connecting them i'll use
letters from the end of the alphabet XYZ
to stand for generic sets and rns for
relations and now one can think of a
relation are going from X to Y the
relation s going from Y to Z what are
these things well R is just a subset of
X cross Y it's a set of ordered pairs of
some kind and same with s it's a subset
of Y cross Z and they come with a notion
of composition so you compose the
relations are an S by essentially saying
X is linked to Z by are composed with F
or as composed with our if I can find
something to mediate that composition so
there has to be some Y such that X is
related to Y and that that same why
should be related to Z if that's the
case then x and z are related by the
composite relation the y that witnesses
the connection is of course hidden when
you finally talked about the composed
relation ok so this is a the absolutely
ordinary notion of binary relation this
is the kind of thing we'd like to
imitate now it's easy to see that
composition is associative we don't have
two parentheses it and it has a very
rich algebraic structure so even though
these are simple things with a simple
notion of relation they can we look at
algebraically for many points of view so
they form what's called a cleaning
algebra which is basically an algebraic
axiomatization of the notion of regular
expressions so cleaning algebras and and
a relations form an example of a cleaner
algebra they form a compact closed
category which perhaps you know what
that is or perhaps you don't but it
doesn't matter
the impressive sounding and importantly
it's the Chrysler category of a
particular monad so I expect people do
not know what kaisi category means nor
what monad means so it is part of my
duty to explain these words right power
set is named after John power no it's
just kidding so so compact close
category edges should just say not
exactly what the definition is but what
it signifies so if you have an NRI
relation you can designate some of those
n elements involved in the relationship
as inputs and the remainder as output
but it really doesn't matter which ones
you designate as input and which ones
you call output you can arbitrarily
repartition it without fundamentally
changing what the relation is and this
ability to freely move things from input
to output is a feature of compact
closure it is in fact exactly the same
feature that you see in finite
dimensional vector spaces and you see
that as manifesting itself as the
ability to form transposes which is
exactly what's happening with relations
or partial transposes and that that
ability is what leads to or standard
ideas of multi linear algebra okay so
relations have all the structure in fact
it's not an accident that relations look
like vector spaces at the categorical
level so just a few propaganda words
about category theory a lot of people
think what the hell does category theory
do for me my daughter says this to be
all the time so if you're looking for
category theory to provide you with you
know seven powerful theorems that will
crack Oh big open problems it doesn't do
that it's more like a guide and a way of
looking at certain things it might
suggest certain constructions to look
for rarely does it actually tell you
just do this and this will happen
sometimes it does but rarely does it do
that so it's in that spirit that i will
be using categorical language it's not
as if i'm going to pull out some theorem
from category theory and immediately
some hard combinatorial problem get
solved
lead a famous computer scientist whose
name I won't mention puts on his list of
10 items that indicate a proof is likely
to be a crackpot one of the items is
uses category theory so so so i'm happy
i'm not going to prove very hard
combinatorial things i'm just going to
use category theory as a way of
suggesting certain constructions okay so
having said that propaganda let's look
at relations from a categorical
perspective so one of the interesting
things about categories is that you can
have the same collection of objects but
with a different notion of morphism and
you'll get some entirely different
mathematical universe so this happens
with set the normal category of sets the
objects are sets the arrows are ordinary
functions they composed of course and
they have the field that's the familiar
universe in which people do standard
mathematics but I can take the same
collection of objects and I'll say now
the arrows are binary relations from X
to Y rather than functions from X to Y
and I get something that looks entirely
different even though it's the same
objects composition in this category is
the relational composition that I talked
about last on the last slide and there
is an identity for associated with each
object it's just a diagonal relation
which relates every element in X to
itself and to nothing else ok so so it
is a category composition is associated
there is an identity blah blah blah it
has all the features of a category as a
category though it looks entirely
different from the category of sets even
though it has exactly the same objects
and this thing can be seen in many other
situations as well as I said it shares
many of the properties of the category
of finite dimensional vector spaces
tensile structure transpose trace in
fact two traces that you can define on
this category associated with different
monoidal structures so in many ways the
category of relations is very much like
the category of finite dimensional
vector spaces and indeed when
categorical quantum mechanics was
developed at Oxford by Sampson Abrams
and Bob cooker and others Peter Selinger
not at Oxford so a lot of emphasis was
placed on activities in quantum
mechanics just in terms of certain kinds
of monoidal categories and the category
of relations was shown as an example of
a kind of a non-standard or deviant
quantum mechanics that has shared many
of the mathematical features but not all
yes use the term mono it'll category can
you say sorry right treat me as a
webpage anything you don't understand go
click and I will explain it so monoidal
category so you have a category equipped
as always with the notion of morphisms
and composition of morphisms identity of
orphans but now i'm going to equip it
with a new gadget called the tensor
product okay and what it is is a by
functor so it will give you for every
pair of object in c it will give you a
new object or two also for every pair of
morphisms it will give you a new
morphism okay so it's exactly the tensor
product so so in the category of sets
and relations the ordinary product
cartesian product is an example of a
monoidal structure but it's a very
special one it has special features that
are not there in all monoidal structures
in the category of finite dimensional
vector spaces over some field the tensor
product that you learned in linear
algebra multi linear algebra is a monoid
instructor so there are a bunch of
axioms that one has to impose in general
which are very very generic but monoidal
categories occur all over the place the
feature or rather the special feature
that's present in the case of the
cartesian product which is not there in
generic monoidal structures is the
ability to project onto the two
components so if i form the tensor
product of vectors there is no way
necessarily
instructing the two vectors from which I
constructed my outer product right yes
so there are many many examples so for
the category of relations you can take
disjoint Union as 11 Idol product you
can take ordinary Cartesian product of
the underlying sets as another one
original structure so particular
category can have two monoidal
structures Samson's Hilbert spaces or
actually their Hilbert's also had a
monoid instructor so basically it's a
fancy word for tensor
now any relation like that correspond
uniquely to a function if you remember
relations they don't have to relate
everything in acts 2 things in Y so
something the next might be left out or
and some things in X might be related to
multiple things in Y so they're
completely wild and barbaric compared to
the strict discipline one imposes on
functions nevertheless there's always an
equivalent function that goes from x
naught to Y but to the power set of Y
and it's defined in a very simple way
you say f of X is simply the set of all
things to which ex might be related and
of course that said could be empty
signifying that this relation doesn't
have to be defined on every single thing
in X and of course this set could be
more than a singleton signifying that a
particular element could be related to
multiple things so you see even though
relations are wild they have in some
natural way an Associated function and
in fact any function like that from X to
the power set of Y defines a binary
relation ok and in fact if I take any
function like this from X to the power
set of why I can lift it with a dagger
do a function from the power set of X to
the power set of why we're all i'm doing
is i'm saying when i apply f dagger to a
subset of x I look at each element in
that subset form the set F of a and take
the Union over all of it ok so this is
just the direct image i will write this
is just F of a ok so we can go back and
forth between thinking of these
relations in the way we were taught as
sets of ordered pairs or think of the
thinking of them as functions going from
X to power set of Y now composition of
these functions if you work it out
corresponds exactly to relational
composition so if I take these dagger
things and compose them if I took
relations constructed the associated
functions lifted them in this way then
compose them and asked now what is this
correspond to indeed it would be just
relational composition so all this is
really elementary stuff
so I want to abstract it and make it a
categorical which will then serve as a
launching point to look at it in a
different matzo set elementary setting
so we see there's an intimate relation
between the category set the category of
relations and the power set operation so
this is the correspondence that I'm
seeking to generalize okay so let's look
at this power set ingredient
categorically so we have this category
of sets and functions we have a functor
called the power set which assigns to
each set the collection of all subsets
which is simply another set and it's
from torial so that means if i have an
arrow from X to Y I get an arrow key of
F that goes from P of X 2 P of Y and it
does the obvious thing it takes the
image okay but there's extra structure
apart from just being a functor it has
the property of being a monad and since
I've not defined what it is I thought I
would actually tell you first through
this example water monad is okay so this
has extra structure for every set there
is a special map that goes from x to the
power set of x and what it does is it
takes the element x and embeds it into
the power set through the singleton
embedding okay so this is a very natural
map all right there's also a very
special and very natural map that says
if you give me a set of sets of X a set
of subsets of X so power set square of X
there's a natural map that takes me from
that do the power set of X and what is
it you give me a family of sets well I
can just take the Union ok and in fact
this is a general theme in monads
basically it says you have two levels of
structure which kind of wipe out one
level of the curly brackets and that
will give you a thing and one level down
okay and this is given by Union both of
these are very natural things to
construct
okay so of course this is a very
irritating word it's like one of those
highly overused word words in
mathematics others are regular and the
third highly overused word is normal so
let me explain what natural means in
this setting it actually means something
technical and indeed it is said I'm not
sure how much I believe it but it is
said that category theory was invented
to make precise this concept of
naturality the original paper was indeed
called the theory of natural
transformations so there it is natural
tea means the following thing it means
that picture but I'll come to the
picture in a minute it says look you're
doing a construction on a whole bunch of
different things and what you want to do
is to do this construction in such a way
that it doesn't use special internal
features of the gadget on which it's
being done ok so I'm constructing the
power set of X I shouldn't look inside X
and say ah i see this particular X has
these special features i will use it in
my construction i should be blind to
that and that blindness is what makes
the construction natural it's not
exploiting special features of X for
example natural constructions in vector
spaces should not look at the basis and
say oh I'll use this basis and do
something very basis specific rather it
should use something that it should be a
construction that says that we just take
the vector space in its most abstract
form and do something with it so there's
a 70 to do with the definition from live
Nets about an object to that windows
sorry you don't have a definition of a
moaner that's the first time I ever
heard of it he is the simulation should
be no no you you know about this ah
afterward of live in its definition of
Morna he's just nicer you use the word
monad I read that it was an object with
our windows which sounds something
similar to what I just there's some
stuff that like it's known as in the
plane I think you can play the island
burger McLain enjoyed using terminology
from philosophers to confuse people
category from Aristotle of functor from
Calabar but I don't think it's related
this dystocia decision is to lay on the
word ma noi yes so that's right so
McLain says in his book that he uses
monad to resemble the word mahanoy so
the word monad came into use a bit later
it was first called something silly like
standard construction no standard can
dual standard construction which is like
a name that doesn't mean anything
perhaps the fourth most overused word
then Mike bar and John Beck started
calling them triples and in fact I I as
you know I work at McGill and we are
forbidden to say monad at least in the
math department were forbidden to say
monad we have to say triples we have to
remember to say triples but outside when
Mike is not watching I say monad so let
me get back to this naturality concept
how does this capture this idea that i'm
not using special features of X so I
have X and I've done something to it I
built this new gadget p of x and now i'm
saying there's this mapping that goes
from x to P of X and what this mapping
is should be not specially dependent on
particular properties of X which be done
in a way that's independent so how do I
capture that I say for any function
whatsoever between X and some other set
why I look at the front oriole
correspondence corresponding function
here and I look at the eight ER there
this should commute so
shouldn't matter whether I did this
thing here and then went there or
whether i first went to why and then did
whatever I normally do on why if I use
some special features of X this would
not work right because that would be
vitiated it by going over to why who
knows I have no control over what F
might be right and this it's highly
unlikely that it will preserve any
special feature of X that I used to
remember this is quantified over all
possible wise and all possible f's that
I care to write down okay so that's the
thing that forces independence of
special features of X on the
construction okay so this is the natural
t diagram for this particular natural
transformation ater right so in this can
be elevated to a general abstract
definition of what it means to have a
natural transformation between two
functors okay so let me give the general
definition of a monad so it's a category
together with an endo functor and do
natural transformations 8ax and mu just
making the properties that i had on the
previous slide this one basically says a
kind of associativity property says
basically if i do t cube and go to T
squared and then to t in one of these
two different ways they should go here
and this one says if i go from t to
tease p of x 2t squared of x using the
front oriole image of the of eight ER
and then apply the operation that takes
me from t squared to t then it shouldn't
matter if i went this way or that way
and indeed they should both give me the
identity okay there's I sorry that's the
identity function the functor that does
nothing or rather it takes everything to
itself it's a fun play like this
you have an object X an object y of
arrow f it takes it to the that
the notation cheap to some power X what
is that d key code okay so T apply to X
means the functor applied to the object
X C cubed means i applied t three times
so in the power set context would be
power set of power set up our set so let
me tell you what this means in the power
set situation maybe it will be more
perspicuous me make sure that the T
squared in mu goes g squared goes to t
that's the same applied twice oh it's I
i see it so it's the functor that is T
applied to itself yes but let me tell
you what it does for power set so so
this was power side I'm taking sets of
sets subsets of X I have some X I take
sets of sets of sets and this thing
fails our first take the union of the
inner things so I have sets of sets then
take the union of that and I'll get
something this thing says first take the
union of the outermost you know brackets
so there I get another set of sets and
take the union of that it shouldn't
matter so it says factor if I have
nested curly brackets
and I say ah you should wipe them out
because that's what Union does one way
of going around that says wipe out these
guys first
you've got this and then the next one
says wipe out these guys and I'll go to
flatten set going around the other way
says wipe out the outer ones first and
then the other one amazing how trivial
it all is when you give it a concrete
example in the right diagram the
parallel lines in the middle what it
means the same oh oh
like thank you okay so that's a generic
monad so I've shown you a monad already
it was kind of the example that drove
the definition maybe I'll show you
another one so monad that's that often
arises in doing automata theory you have
a set X you form the set of all words
actually giving you a monoid but don't
tell anyone we just pretend it's a set
so we view this functor we call it t
going from set to set is this really a
monad well let's see do I have a way of
going from this do that well sure x star
is a set of strings this is strings of
strings and what do you do concatenate
them you get a string do I have a way of
doing that sure I do I take a letter and
regard it as a string it's exactly the
analog of the what I was doing in power
sets do I have that kind of square law
well if I have strings of strings the
strings and I wipe out the levels of
structure until it's completely
flattened it doesn't matter in which
order I wipe it out so you see these
things are saying very generic things
yes rightmost arrow going down what is
the label of that supposed to be that's
T of T 0 beta of X I'm sorry this one
yeah yeah it should be T 0 beta of X oh
that's really very sorry as new of X yes
yes that's to you later of X that's new
of X going from T squared to t so that
it's the same as it's the same view as
the other other yes
yes this one this one should have had a
Mew of X I didn't expect anybody was
going to look at this one
why the hell do people do this okay so
this is the categorical way of doing
universal algebra so I don't want to go
at length into universal algebra here
Don categorically but given a monad you
can construct algebras from a monad
so how does this work so if I have them
on ad I look at a particular exon which
this Mon are acts so I get this new
object T of X and I may or may not find
an arrow like this let's say I do such a
thing is called an algebra 40
now if you look at this monad of strings
thing that I did and you asked what on
earth does algebra for that thing mean
well it says I have a way doing that I
way of going from here to here and you
can see from these equations it's
exactly defining a mano it so in fact
the category of monoids can be
constructed as the category of algebra
is for that particular monad and there
are a couple of diagrams that are
lighting that have to be added for the
category of elddim to be an algebra so
but the basic structure you can see
emerging it says you have to give me a
rule that tells me how to convert a
sequence of these things into a single
thing and it's basically more annoyed
multiplication okay but this is not the
category I wanted to talk about given
them on ad there are two Associated
categories that one considers in general
one is the so-called island berg more
category the category of algebra and it
leads to the categorical way of doing
universal algebra there is another one
called the Chrysler category okay so as
I just said monads are the main
ingredient in the categorical treatment
of universal algebra but I don't want to
do that what I'd like to do is show
another closely related construction you
can do if you have a monad that yields
yet another category so here's how it
works so you are given a monad t on some
category c and i'm going to define a new
category c sub T with the same objects
as you have in C and I think it would be
easier for you to follow if I do this on
the board rather than have it flush at
you on the slides
so the objects of this category are
exactly the same as they were before so
I have objects x and y from my category
c remember i said you can have the same
objects and just change what the notion
of morphism is so i'm going to define a
new category by changing the morphisms
not by changing the objects okay so what
are the new morphisms so i'll say a
morphism f in CT is a morphism also
called F from x 2 t y in c right so this
is called the Chrysler category but
before we get ahead of ourselves I have
to tell you how to compose these things
because arrows have to be composed now
in C we know how to compose things so
let's say I have an arrow from X to Y in
CT and a wire arrow from Y to Z also in
CT somehow I have to construct an arrow
from X to Z I'd like to call that G
circle F in CT ok so you say look these
arrows in CT are just actually related
arrows in C and I know how to compose
things there so let's do it
alright so you go x 2 t y so this F from
X to Y in CT was really an arrow f from
x 2 t y and then you say gee goes from y
2 TZ and you see these don't match up
okay but we do have this funk dirty
sitting around so we can apply t to
everything now they do match up okay so
i can indeed go like this
that's good unfortunately I was supposed
to wind up in TZ not in T squared Z but
I have mu
it knows how to smash me back down to
tea so this gives me a composition rule
for the clys d category if you look what
happened with the power set I had a
function from X to power set I looked at
its direct image then I got too many
things it was sets of sets of things in
Y but then I smashed them down that's
exactly taking the direct image that
formula if you remember had a union in
it and this new map is nothing but
taking union of a family ok so you can
see how the Chrysler category
construction is mimicking what I did
before with with the power set functor
ok so this is just describing what I've
told you on the board ok so doing this
with P is exactly what we did before and
gives relational composition so this
tells you how the power set viewed as a
monad yields another category called the
classy category of that Mon art and that
crazy category is the category of
relations so all this is super fancy
abstract way of doing something that you
probably you how to do anyway but let us
follow this path again on less familiar
territory ok so we start with measurable
spaces the objects are measurable spaces
as I described yesterday and the arrows
are measurable functions we know that
they compose a former category in many
ways this category of measure spaces is
of measurable spaces is just like set it
isn't exactly like it but it has many
similar features in fact it's something
called a topological concrete category
so it's complete adco complete so so you
have lots of space to do stuff lots of
ability to do constructions in this
category now what about adding
probability measures to this picture so
you can say all right my objects will be
not just sets equipped with Sigma
algebra but also with probability
measures and i'm going to say the arrows
have to be measurable and perhaps also
measure preserving and you can get a
category this way it tends to be wrong
ridgid it's easy to say what it means to
be measure preserving it basically says
the image measure under this measurable
function has to match the measure that's
already there so you can define a
category like that it tends to be kind
of awkward and things don't work so well
in it there are ways of getting around
it and there are categories one can
construct and do certain things with but
it turns out to be much more fruitful to
put the probabilities into the arrows
and not attach them to the spaces so
that's what I'm going to do maybe maybe
it's too elaborate to say but can you
see what does not have products mean
right
it is first know my whole purpose is for
you to ask questions like that okay so a
product says if you have two objects I
can construct a third object that i'll
call the product which has certain
special properties it's equipped with
maps like this
oh yeah welded yes they call the
projections in set but in general we
just demanded there so how do I say
something like projections without
talking elements Dexter cozen wrote a
song called categories uber alles you
can find the words on the on the
internet somewhere and one of the lines
was we know that elements are just a
hack so we have to try and say these
things without talking about elements so
I'd like to be able to normally we would
say oh look we have set pairs of
elements you grab one or the other but I
somehow have to say that just with
arrows so we'll say give me a third
object z supposing I'm equipped with
morphisms like that then there has to be
a unique morphism from Z into X cross Y
such that everything commutes and this
is exactly the property that the
Cartesian product hasn't set to say that
this category does not have product
means I can't always do this
so this is one of the senses in which I
mean category theory guides you you will
start building up some constructions
than you ask gee I wonder if I have
products and then you find I do or I
don't and you start thinking perhaps my
definition needs to be different so it's
a guide not an answer and so now we come
to the laverre jury monad which is the
way we're going to define probabilistic
relations the analog of what with all
the simple things we did before so the
underlying category is memorized we're
going to define a functor an endo
functor gamma named in honor of michelle
GD from meds to mez so this morn ad was
actually discovered by levier and
written up in a typescript called the
category of probabilistic mappings and
he clearly was aware that it has a monad
he just didn't use this language so how
does it work endo found her own mess so
takes a set equipped with the Sigma
algebra and it produces this thing the
set of all probability measures defined
on that Sigma algebra so these are set
functions this is just a set I have to
also give it a Sigma algebra right
because it's supposed to be an end of
hunter on meds not on set but already
you can see mmm this is some kind of
probabilistic analog of the power set
just like as before I had the set of all
sets now I have the set of all
probability measures I don't like to use
the f-word so I will call it a
probabilistic analog of power set now
gamma-x needs to have a Sigma algebra
structure on it so how do I do that for
every measurable set there's a natural
function as I shouldn't use that word
too often there is a nice function
called evaluate at a defined like so so
what it does is it says you give me a
measure and I will give you a number
between 0 and 1 and how do I produce
that number you give me the measure and
I'll just evaluate that measure on the
set a ok so for every a there is such a
function evaluate a day
so what I'm going to do is end dow my
collection gamma of x with the smallest
Sigma algebra making all of these maps
I'm sorry this was a typo it should be
easy of a measurable okay so all these
evaluation maps should be made
measurable now what do I mean by
smallest Sigma algebra so if I make
every single set measurable then every
single function in creation will be
measurable because inverse image of
measurable sets have to be measurable so
I'd like to be as conservative as
possible about deeming sets to be
measurable just enough to make all these
functions measurable functions so you
can give a more explicit description but
this is the one that really gives you a
feeling for how the Sigma algebra
structure is put on this it has to be a
functor to write so given a measurable
function from here to here what's the
arrow part of that functor well it's
just composing with the inverse image
that of course will take you from gamma
X 2 gamma Y as it is done here now I
claim this thing is actually a monarch
so I need to give you a map ater and a
map mu and these should be as I'm very
much trying to mimic the power set these
should be evocative of the singleton
embedding and of the Union so what's the
singleton embedding well then obvious
thing to do of course is the Dirac Delta
distribution so what it does is it says
I will map every point in X to a
suitable measure the measure whose
entire mass is concentrated at that
point ok so this was the direct measure
that I introduced yesterday so this is
just like a probabilistic power set with
a singleton embedding but what is the
analog of Union so that's not so clear
so what do we need from our union it
said it should take distributions over
distributions and flatten them out and
give you a single distribution right
just like set up sets should be
flattened out to a single set I have to
take distributions over distributions
and flatten it out to a single
distribution okay so let me use capital
Omega to stand for a generic element of
this collection so it's a measure on
gamma X it's a measure on the space of
measures all right and when I mu of that
has to be a measure on this thing right
it has to be an element of gamma x IE a
measure on x sigma okay what is a
measure on x sigma it says if you give
me a measurable set i'll give you a
number okay so give me an Omega give me
a measurable set I should manufacture a
number what can I possibly do to get
this number now you recall that these
evaluation functions from gamma x 201
are measurable functions we set up the
Sigma algebra on gamma X precisely to
make these things measurable functions
right so we've got a measurable function
we've got to measure their dying to get
together so we say mu X on Omega viewed
as a measure right it's now gotten
flattened so it's a measure on Sigma so
it knows how to assign a number to the
measurable set a and how does it do that
it integrates over the space gamma X
this function e v sub a using that as
the integration measure
right so this was less obvious but it is
a perfect analogy with the with the
union construction now numerous
equations have to be checked and
yesterday I describe something that I
call the monotone convergence mantra you
can check all those equations very
easily on the special case when you're
working with just characteristic
functions and then you just invoke the
mantra and the everything else actually
follows quite readily so the monotone
convergence theorem is really powerful
for this so these are going to be the
Chrysler category for this monad are
going to be my probabilistic relations
let's look at them more closely the
objects are measurable spaces a map H
from X to Y lambda is a measurable
function from X to gamma Y right that's
how my client category worked ok so what
is it so it says it's a map from X to
the space that map's elements of lambda
2 0 1 but I can curry this I never
remember which one is currying and which
one is uncaring but you know what I mean
and we can rewrite this as a map from X
cross lambda 2 0 1 so I'll view this as
a 2 argument gadget the first argument
is a point in X the second argument is a
measurable set in Y and it assigns a
number and what the category forces on
you is you say that if I fix the set B
in lambda and let this point very it has
to be a measurable function if I fix the
point X and let the set very it has to
be a measure so that's the type of this
gadget ok and in fact these are
precisely what I called Markov kernels
yesterday also known as regular
conditional probability densities so
they're not almost everywhere ok they're
absolutely everywhere ok right so those
regular conditional probability
densities emerge precisely from the
closely category of this G Ramona
ok and they compose in just the way that
you expect so let's compose them so I
have a map from X to Y and a map k from
Y to Z and the composite map should go
from X to Z so it should say give me a
point X from X and immeasurable subset C
of Z and please produce for me a number
ok so so what is that number well if I
fix the set C I've got this measurable
function in Y if I fix this point X I've
got a measure on why so again I've got a
measurable function y a measure on why I
integrate over Y and this is exactly the
thing that I get by composing these
markov kernels and you can see the
analogy with relational composition
integration is playing the role of the
existential quantifier to hide the
middle witness and in fact if you say oh
these are discrete sets so that these
are just points let's say finite sets
hey this is matrix multiplication so in
fact this is how we compose the
transition matrices of Markov chains
also Viceroy mark by matrix
multiplication all right so i will call
this category s rel for stochastic
relations now we can use this all this
machinery to give sintac to give
semantics to Cozens language so let me
quickly remind you of Cozens language
it's just a language with ordinary
assignment statements we are not being
very specific about what these f's might
be but let's imagine the language is
equipped with some primitive functions
for doing arithmetic we have composition
of imperative commands in the usual
sense sequential composition a
conditional and it an iteration
construct with boolean expressions
guarding both these things there's no
probability explicitly in this syntax as
I said on Monday you can readily add it
with no additional difficulty or you can
imagine that what this language is
working on our variables that are
already
got probability distributions associated
with them rather than precise values and
you're viewing these things as
transforming those distributions so
there are a fixed set of variables
taking values in measurable space in
some measurable space and we assume that
these eps are measurable functions and
that these bees define measurable
subsets if you give some me some
relatively harmless syntax for writing
boolean expressions that will easily
turn out to be the case so the semantics
is basically a well I'll show you or
sketch two of them for you one is called
the state transform of semantics and it
takes a distribution and transforms it
into a new distribution as the program
executes variables get manipulated and
the input distribution gets transformed
into an output distribution so this is
the state transform of semantics and
indeed the meaning of a statement will
be a Markov Colonel ie an S rail
morphism the only subtle part in all
this is how to give fixed point
semantics to the while loop okay so in
order to do that let me show you a bit
of structure so here is a very tiny
variation on Jerry's monad embarrassing
Lee if you google penang garden monad
you will get this thing which is really
too small a variation to be worthy of a
name but anyway this is how it works the
only difference is instead of
probability distributions I'm going to
allow sub probability distributions so
the total mass associate of total
probability measure associated with the
entire space X may perhaps be less than
1 okay so sub probability distributions
now everything else is defined exactly
as in gamma it works the same the Monad
maps etc the natural transformations and
from now on i will use srl to stand for
the tri-city category of this mon at pi
why bother to make this little change
well intuitively in this language of
while loops you might have non
termination some of the probability mass
might evaporate into the non terminating
loops
so if you're trying to say I have some
distribution over the final output well
they're aight not be any output because
the thing might never terminate okay so
mathematically you get a new level of
structure which is that the home sets
the collection of morphisms between two
objects now have additive structure or
to be precise partially additive
structure now you can't add two
probability distributions just you know
brutally because it might happen to the
total probability associated with the
whole space is more than one even if
there are sub probability distributions
each of them might say the total space
has total probability three quarters
then you get one and a half and you'll
have to do physics to fix that but what
you can do is you can say we will define
certain families called summable
families and summable families simply
mean others that we can some safely okay
and a summable family may even be
infinite so you can oxidize the theory
of categories where the home sets have
been enriched with this partially
additive structure and they're called
partially additive categories so the
home sets indeed form these so-called
partially additive monoids I don't want
to write down all the numerous equations
you can probably guess them better than
then you would understand them if I
flush them at you if I said come up with
the right equations you probably would
so these things are called partially
additive monoids the axioms allow you to
do things like rearrange things at will
this is a kind of associativity property
and there is a nice limit property which
you will which is pleasant to impose so
if you have a countable family in which
every finite sub family is summable then
the whole family has to be some of them
so this is called the limit axiom for a
partially additive monoid and you would
like the sums to interact properly with
composition so you would like
composition to distribute over sums in
the right way and so forth
okay and then this an axiom called the
untying axiom if you have x going into a
countable co-product of wise then you
kind of extract the individual pieces
then what you get has to be a summable
family because after all the original
thing was a well-defined morphism it
can't be that any one of the pieces
cannot be added okay so why does this
structure matter so there's a nice
theorem proved by our bebin manners
which says if you have a partially
additive category like that and a
morphism f from X to Y then you can find
a morphism f star constructed as you can
see from this countable sum which we
will call the iterative f now this
equation might be readable or not but
the following picture will tell you
what's happening
so I have a morphism f going like this
from X to X plus y
so what this thing says is well you can
decompose that into a morphism from X to
Y and another one from X to X not a big
surprise but importantly you can feed
this back
and what this formula the way you can
read it is you think of a particle going
through this and you say hmm it has some
probably to exit right away or it goes
here goes through the loop and then it's
faced with the same decision goes here
goes through the loop so you can sum all
that that sum is exactly what is being
represented by this sum the sum of all
those possibilities so you can see this
is actually capturing the notion of
iteration what is nice is that you can
show quite readily that this has to be a
sammobile family if the f that you
started with came from such a thing okay
so it says basically this partially
editor so notice if I didn't have these
sub probability distributions nothing
would be additive the only the singleton
families would be additive the fact that
I have sub probabilities allows me to
have this additive structure that's what
allows me to have this iteration and
that's what allows me to give semantics
to Cozens language so this is equivalent
to the semantics that goes in himself
gave but it's not how he did it this was
done by me quite a bit later so now we
can do the semantics of chosens language
in terms of these kinds of morphisms so
the assignment statement is this
god-awful mess but if you look at it
closely what is it saying it's just the
Dirac distribution on this assignment ok
everything else basically says the point
stay where they were but this guy gets
updated to f of X the potential
composition is just composition but this
composition is the Estoril composition
not function composition conditionals
again you just split be and the
measurable sets defined by be into it
and its complement and apply s1 or s2 as
appropriate and finally for the while
loop you look at the two spaces that you
get corresponding to the conditional or
its complement you get a map h of the
appropriate type and then you can use
its iterate to give the semantics of the
while loop so
so that's the power of having this
partially additive structure so the
probabilistic relation idea gives you a
kind of smooth transition from what we
were doing with ordinary transition
systems and ordinary relations and we
have now gone into the world of
probabilistic transition systems so
tomorrow I will study probabilistic
transition systems in over continuous
spaces in some detail and we will talk
about when two states of such a system
behave the same way you define a concept
called by simulation which captures
exactly this concept of by similarity
and we will prove a theorem that tells
you that two systems are by similar or
two states are by similar exactly when
they agree on the formulas of a certain
modal logic so this is exactly the kind
of theorem that fan Bentham proved and
later and I guess independently Hennessy
and Milne approved for ordinary
transition systems but we will do it in
the probabilistic case okay so I will
stop here and take questions if anybody
has any causes in revenge is a measure
of a set right would be the boolean
expression it's interpreted as a
defining a measurable set so somehow
intuitively we sought to say that while
if this has positive measurement is
non-negative but that's not what's
happening right no it's are you in this
set or not yeah that's what if it's
supposed to do right do you satisfy this
property so b is defining some
measurable set and it's asking you are
you in there said if so do this if
you're not do that
that's does this people
so in this chosen language the way
you're giving semantics to it you're
viewing these programs in crossings
language as transformers from properly
decisions are measured to it to measures
but in causing constructs themselves
don't involve any probabilities right
augments closings language with actually
flip coin flips yes yes absolutely
absolutely trivial to do that yes and
that's why also another reason why I
would like additive structure because
you will then take convex sums of these
estoril morphisms because in that sense
if you do that then you don't even need
to start out with distribution on the
infamy you could have that's right yeah
yes will you start with direct
distributions yep yep yep so it's very
easy to do that and I believe maybe in
his paper he did that I just didn't
bother to do that I just want to say one
more thing it's possible to give a dual
semantics as well so just as in ordinary
programming languages you have a
so-called forward semantics where you
say here is the original state of the
program and it evolves as the program
executes you have a so-called weakest
preconditions semantics so you say this
was true at the end what must have
happened before and it's kind of a
backward flow and so this is called the
dual to semantic so you can construct a
category of probabilistic predicate
transformers the stochastic analogue of
Dijkstra's predicate transformers again
objects are measurable spaces so now
given a set with a Sigma algebra you can
construct a space of bounded measurable
functions you can think of these are the
predicates the random variables are the
predicates these are what you're
observing sorry and a morphism is a now
a bounded linear map from this space f
of x 2 f of y ok so that's what it is
why do I feel I have the right to call
these things predicate transformers
because you can actually prove a duality
between these two categories if you look
at the category of stochastic relations
up it's exactly this
degree of stochastic per ticket
transformers okay so there's a nice
stone type duality between the forward
semantics and the and the dual backward
semantics ok so somebody should ask me
what stone type duality yes so i will
tell you that's how all the time
informally ok this is now i'm really
going to stop any more questions no ok
so we should go for the last break